Trascrizione: Inesse Saidani
Revisore: Cristina Bufi-Pöcksteiner
Ognuno di noi ha
delle sensibilità particolari.
Io amo passeggiare,
scoprire posti nuovi,
incontrare persone che hanno il sole,
il vento, la terra tra le dita.
Amo vedere con i miei occhi
i paesaggi dall'alto
e sentire quel profumo di buono
che c'è nell'aria,
quando sei lì, proprio dove vuoi essere.
Ho scoperto poco a poco che la mia
è un'anima da cercatrice d'oro.
Quando ad un certo punto della mia vita
ho capito che il lavoro che avevo
non faceva per me
e che quindi era arrivato il momento
di cambiare strada,
mi sono sentita come quel cercatore
d'oro che vuole arrivare in cima
alla montagna,
anzi, dentro la montagna.
Io ero però ancora in pianura,
a chilometri di distanza.
Non sapevo dove fosse la miniera,
non sapevo chi avrei incontrato
lungo il cammino.
Ma avevo una grande fiducia
nella mia intuizione.
Questa è una cosa
che ognuno di noi ha,
almeno in una certa misura.
I ho capito, strada facendo,
che la mia anima da cercatrice d'oro mi piaceva.
Ho esplorato il territorio
in cui ero nata e ne ho visto le bellezze.
E volevo che altri partecipassero
dello stesso sguardo.
E che chi ci vive, o ci passa,
o ci capita per puro caso,
potesse godere di quelle pepite,
come le godevo io.
Pepite spesso piccole,
nascoste,
spesso non sufficientemente valorizzate.
Ho cominciato trovandone una,
poi un'altra, poi un sacco intero.
E la cosa bella
è che mi sono resa
conto ad un certo punto
che ero in grado di far dialogare
quei piccoli gioielli
tra di loro.
Perché la bellezza, si sa,
spesso è contagiosa.
È cominciata così un'avventura
che va avanti da più di 3 anni
e va a gonfie vele.
Le pepite che ho incontrato
sul mio cammino sono tutte le realtà
del Trentino Alto Adige che si occupano
in maniera autentica di bambini
e di famiglie.
E come potete immaginare,
è un interesse piuttosto ampio.
Il problema principale dei genitori,
o degli adulti di riferimento,
è che spesso non sanno dove andare,
non conoscono il territorio.
Sono ripetitivi e soprattutto
non amano affatto le sorprese.
Eppure il nostro territorio
è un'autentica miniera
di luoghi davvero incantevoli.
Ve ne faccio conoscere alcuni.
C'è una panchina dove, quando arrivi,
ti sembra di essere
il padrone del mondo.
Quando sei lì,
nient'altro esiste.
C'è una miniera,
la casa dei Sette Nani con i mantelli,
le tazzine e dei piccoli lettini.
Ci sono
torrenti da esplorare e pozze
color smeraldo da saltarci dentro
e
un lago da percorrere in kayak,
che ti sembra di essere
nel Grand Canyon.
Ci sono cani da valanga,
che ti vengono a cercare,
quando ti nascondi dentro la neve.
E
strumenti musicali sconosciuti,
da suonare in una giornata di pioggia.
Ci sono insomma ogni giorno,
in tanti angoli del Trentino Alto Adige,
dei luoghi incantevoli,
che possono regalare
delle esperienze indimenticabili,
sia ai grandi che ai piccoli.
Grande territorio, grandi opportunità,
ma torniamo al punto.
Come farne un lavoro?
La chiave era diventare
un'ambasciatrice del territorio,
descriverlo in maniera veritiera,
stimolare e promuovere
le realtà più belle,
coinvolgere le persone facendo venire
loro la voglia di andare in quei posti
e vederli con i propri occhi.
Una delle prime cose
di cui mi sono resa conto,
quando ho cominciato questa avventura,
è che accanto all'intuizione
e alla capacità di cogliere
la qualità delle proposte,
ero capace di fare bene un'altra cosa:
raccontarlo agli altri.
Non so se tutti voi siete d'accordo
con me, ma io sono convinta che una cosa,
quando viene condivisa,
diventi più bella e più preziosa.
E sapevo farlo e funzionava,
perché poi quelle persone,
quando leggevano il mio racconto,
in quei posti ci andavano davvero.
E trovavano conferma nel mio racconto
e me lo dicevano e lo dicevano agli altri.
E la cosa funzionava tanto,
e funziona tutt'ora,
che spesso e volentieri, gli operatori,
specialmente quelli più piccoli,
mi chiamavano per dire
e raccontarmi che
improvvisamente avevano registrato
il tutto esaurito.
E anzi mi chiedevano
--ormai è una prassi consolidata--
di avvertirli in caso
di una nuova recensione,
per essere pronti
a ricevere tutte quelle persone.
Com'è che, si chiedevano, improvvisamente,
in una grigia giornata di novembre,
arrivano un sacco di telefonate
di prenotazione per i nostri tavoli.
Perché, improvvisamente,
tutti chiedono dell'asino Galileo,
se c'è in fattoria.
E perché tra le tante proposte del menù,
vogliono tutti gli gnocchi
realizzati con le ortiche?
Il passaparola cresceva rapidamente.
Il progetto è stato recepito
dagli utenti con grande entusiasmo
e poi anche dagli operatori,
che hanno cominciato a chiederci:
"Hey Silvia, racconta anche me".
Avrete notato che ogni tanto dico io
e ogni tanto dico noi.
Ho cominciato da sola, ma ben presto,
lungo il cammino, si sono aggiunti
altri cercatori d'oro.
Ora siamo
un gruppo, una squadra,
che va ogni giorno
alla ricerca di nuove pepite.
Condividiamo la stessa passione:
la fiducia nelle cose ben fatte
e la certezza che raccontarle
serve a chi le crea
e a chi ne gode.
Non è stato sempre un cammino semplice,
perché io volevo mantenere le promesse
fatte inizialmente.
Quando leggo qualcosa
voglio poterci credere
e lo stesso volevo che avvenisse
con le persone
che avevano fiducia in me.
Ho rinunciato quindi
a budget considerevoli.
Quando mi chiedevano
di promuovere delle realtà
a mio avviso non meritevoli.
Come avrete intuito,
il denaro per me non è la priorità.
La priorità per me è
mantenere la reputazione,
una reputazione costruita ogni giorno,
passo dopo passo, con fatica.
Quando uno si scopre cercatore d'oro
poi lo rimane per sempre.
E ha due possibilità
o costruire un deposito,
come zio Paperone,
oppure reinvestire quelle pepite
nel territorio,
con nuovi progetti,
da condividere un'altra volta.
Il successo di pubblico, la risposta
del pubblico mi ha convinta a cominciare,
un'altra volta,
a iniziare una nuova avventura.
Sta partendo proprio in questi mesi,
sta prendendo
concretezza un'altra idea.
Un portale, un sito dedicato ai grandi.
Perché di tesori ce ne sono tanti,
ma una giornata o un luogo indimenticabile
è un regalo ad ogni età.
La morale della storia?
Io non lo so se c'è,
però mi ripeto spesso che,
in un periodo storico
che ha messo in crisi più di una persona
e che
di certo non brilla per la promozione
di nuove iniziative,
è ancora possibile provare a volare.
Io avevo un nido stabile e sicuro.
L'ho lasciato per il mio volo.
E questo volo è alla portata di chiunque,
chiunque creda nelle proprie idee
e abbia voglia di investire
tempo e fatica.
È semplicemente questa la mia ricetta,
la ricetta per imparare
a spiegare le proprie ali.
Grazie.
(Applausi)